winter is coming and no one can stop it
Game of Thrones season 6 episode 8 no
one this is your spoiler warning I don't
just boiler for any more it's a really
good episode go watch it there's a lot
that I like in this episode and most of
it is unjust small moments and little
things this episode as a whole is just a
conglomeration of a lot of little things
that I like there's some big things too
and I'll kind of get to those but I just
kind of want to rattle through the
little moments that were just great
cheering finally getting those other two
to have a drink and loosen up Braun and
Podrick together I actually forgotten
how good those two are the mountain
finally gets to kill somebody I actually
really kind of wish she could have
killed more than just the one guy but
you know what I think that was more than
covered with the hounds opening coming
in with the axe so you know what call
that balanced the Brotherhood brothers
without banners wow we have not seen
that in a long time Breanna and Jamie
together it was good it was sweet it was
true to the characters it could have
been so easy to go overboard with that
scene they didn't they held it in check
I thought the way Riverrun resolved was
fairly interesting that they were able
to take that castle without a huge
battle no shots fired and it ended on
just the right note with brianne and pod
rowing away and Jamie just letting them
go I've said recently that I'm worried
that the show as a whole is becoming
slightly more predictable and I still
kind of stand by that I think in the
broad strokes there's only so many ways
it can go as it gets closer and closer
to the end but it's still finding little
ways to surprise me like with Tommen
just disbanding trial by combat I didn't
see that coming I mean the big part of
why didn't see that coming is I had
assumed that okay the mountains got to
be her champion the hound has got to get
all the way back to King's Landing so he
can face the mountain and he can have
that revenge that we know he wanted for
a very long time now that's not gonna
happen which now frees up the hound I
don't know where he's gonna go and
that's nice I kind of needed more things
where I didn't feel like I had a clear
path of what was going to happen
although speaking of knowing what was
going to happen I totally called Arya
being able to take that girl in the dark
and ru reclaims
name she's headed out long time coming
at just that little grin from the
faceless assassin that was really good
to see cuz it means he's gonna let her
go excellent there were just a lot of
moments in this one that had me going
yeah pretty much everything with the
Hound an heiress coming back in the way
she came in the timing of it as soon as
I your bull to random like she's gonna
get to that dark corner where she put
needle and yeah I was missing her get
there I'm not sure what else there is to
say this was just a really good really
strong episode a lot of good bits that i
like things moving forward we finally
got more of Chi burn again we haven't
seen him in a bit and i'm really i'm
very curious as to sort of where he's
going what he's up to if there's one
quick it's maybe not even a criticism
because I day at once we hit the end of
the season maybe it'll become clear but
as of right now at the end of this
episode I find myself questioning the
point of the entire River Run divergence
I mean it brought several characters
back that we hadn't seen for a while
blackfish Edmure obviously the phrase
are involved in this but the thing is
all these characters have been
completely out of circulation you bring
them back forward this thing and then
resolve this thing and I'm not sure how
it impacted anything else like so far as
I can tell the only practical upshot of
any of it was it got bran away from the
upcoming battle at a Winterfell although
she may still make it back in time to
participate in that and it got Jamie
away from King's Landing so you know
maybe he would have had snow some
reaction to the pickle that Searcy's in
but that's that's pretty minimal impact
for something that's eaten up a fair
amount of screen time so right now I'm
questioning you know what what did we
accomplish with all this now as I said
once we hit the end of the season maybe
you know there'll be some added bit some
new nuggets that'll make it clear why we
had to take the time and spend it here
so I'm sort of leaving the door open for
this to not register as a complaint but
it so right now i'll call it a concern
and so excited for the next episode i
really i really think we might get
Ramsey killed I mean I think we kind of
have to by the end of the season because
I mean after this
we're getting like 13 episodes after
this you know maybe they'll break it up
into two seasons like they said but
that's not a lot to go they got it they
got a head for the big climax with that
stuff and they got to get the little
distraction out of the way and
ultimately Ramsey is a little
distraction he is a he's a little fish
they got to start focusing on the shark
so I'm hoping hoping Rams yield I mean
how else can I better go they're not
gonna kill John again but anyway we'll
see i'm looking forward to that and i
did enjoy this episode it was good it
was fun it was funny there was a lot of
good humor in this one too so no one
have you seen it what did you think
about this particular episode whatever
you thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe follow me on
Twitter I council of geeks check out the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned